what would you say to the women that are
saying to you I'm perfectly happy if my
boyfriend decides to paint his nails and
wear pearls and put a dress on I don't
think that you're up with the times here
I would say
I would say for you that's also
perfectly fine there may be variation
between women in that but years ago they
really tried to push the softer gentler
Kinder view of guys and romance novels
and they didn't sell well because even
if in your daily life it might be easier
to have a guy that would do whatever you
wanted no matter what that might not be
what you fantasize about in the same
sense that men may fantasize about women
that they would never get in real life
if you're an unattractive male who is
older and doesn't have any resources
you're not going to get the average star
but that doesn't mean that that's not
what floats your boat it is almost kind
of an objective desire that may not
match up with what you would want as a
long-term partner there may be some
differences there that women have well
it might be what you might want but also
might not be what you can get